it's time for drew's news your daily
look at but those
good new shaped clouds and always with
me is my co-pilot ross matthias that's
right
first up tis the season for sex and the
city
i know
and just like that finally premiered on
hbo max and we have kristin davis here
later to talk about the celebration
of the return of an institution now the
new york post reports that she and
cynthia nixon recently revealed on
colbert that they shot fake scenes
to keep the fans guessing they would be
shooting all around the city and i think
we saw every long lens photograph i mean
i feel like i know more about the show
because of the paparazzi yes but
apparently
it might have all been a ruse
rossi i know have you seen anything of
the show because i'm hearing that you
did
i okay
yes and i have to make a confession and
then but yes i the second it came out i
watched the first two episodes they're
out you guys i watch them
and i'll just say that you don't even
know what you don't even know until you
know what you know and i was at first
when i heard that they were filming
scenes to sort of screw with my head i
was like how dare you but now having the
experience of watching it i'm so
grateful i didn't know
because now i know
and
drew have you haven't no here's my
confession are you ready wellington my
fiance and i were planned to watch it
together
but i couldn't wait
and
so i lied to him and i
i blame i blamed you i said yeah
i did i said you know kristen davis is
coming on the show so i sort of i'm a
professional so i kind of have to watch
it without you i mean it means a lot to
drew that i show up prepared
so
it's true wellington we all had to watch
it for research
i know oh my god are you gonna tell him
the truth he watches every day so
call me at commercial
i will say wellington i do understand
that not being able to wait i mean i i
cannot wait to get home tonight and
start this when you see it you have to
text me okay i will text you immediately
please can you also text welly and just
apologize yep 100 thank you that's what
i'm here for roxy your story all right
next up one of our favorite canadian
treasures of all time can we get a what
what for ryan reynolds
that's not
a hard name to say
ryan reynolds yes we love him he's
making headlines for taking a break
people reports ryan's stepping away from
acting for a while to focus on being a
dad he and blake lively they have three
daughters james inez and betty all
between two and six and he says when you
act you've got to travel and he wants to
be home with the girls and i know you
know can relate to this because you sort
of make a similar shift in your life for
your daughters right i really did i have
not heard anyone say anything like this
i'm amazed to hear him talk about that
do you think it's like kids that changes
everything for you is that what happened
with you like when you had the girls
were you just like that's the most
important thing
changed everything in me did you think
that was ever going to happen that you
could ever make that shift in your mind
because i i don't have kids i can't
imagine it but you see it happen with
people i i it's true rossi i i never
thought that i would be in the places
that i've been through my kids like they
have definitely made me grow the most
they've made me work on myself the
hardest they've made me make decisions
that were higher road and bigger than
myself
and the least selfish i've ever been in
my life and it has all worked out so
well to put them first
but
it's so interesting for someone like
ryan reynolds who is such a big movie
star very prolific working all the time
major important entity for our industry
hello deadpool um and for him to sort of
make this claim is very
tender and it's always great to hear dad
saying like i want to spend time with my
kids and this might be a short long or
medium lived journey
but i thank him for bringing us along
with it so we can understand where he's
at because i will say i do think the
world really roots for this man oh
absolutely i mean he's a superhero he's
a dad he's a human and kids
kids can change you you know
well kids made deadpool take a break and
kids can also shock us here's a story
about a three-year-old with something
interesting in her sippy cup drew you're
gonna love this this story went viral
the daily mail reports lauren scanlon a
mom from pennsylvania she got an
emergency call from her daughter
payton's preschool when they found a
fish in her sippy cup
yep
the fish was peyton's a pet betta fish
named mermaid oh
payden loved mermaids so she snuck her
into her cup that morning
and look
and the teacher only noticed when peyton
drank from it at snack time
and peyton i guess loves mermaid so much
but forgot that she put the fish in
there and we are happy to report both
peyton and the fish are back home and
doing very well
[Applause]
but
props to that teacher
that teacher who noticed and said hey
something fishy is going on
but that's cute did you girls ever do
that where they wanted to bring another
person
if either of them heard this story they
would be taking their fish to school
absolutely really well mermaid peyton's
fish got a good life she gets to travel
see the world thank you
well next up we've got your holiday din
din in a tin tin
i'm a little worried about this
food news
[Applause]
i don't think
i don't think we've ever been more
scared about a food news drew well
interesting because the guardian reports
that heinz uk is launching a brand new
soup for the holidays
it's called christmas dinner in a can
and this soup has got everything we're
talking turkey brussels sprouts stuffing
potatoes pigs in a blanket gravy and
cranberry sauce the kitchen sink of
holidays is now in a bowl now did you
just can you just say that again did you
say pigs in a blanket are in the soup
because i just found a pig in a blanket
look at this so they're in the soup
they're um there are pigs in a blanket
there's also stuffing balls
okay oh god
it smells like
when i
it smells like everything yeah it smells
like you know what it also smells like
heinz baked beans which i'm a huge fan
of yeah
i have this coupon book that drew gave
me for christmas and this first one says
pass on eating a food item at the desk
but
but i'm going to save that for a
carbohydrate and i'm going to i'm going
to try this drew are you going to try it
i'm going in for the stuffing ball
because you know
yeah i got it
okay
really okay
[Music]
you know what i totally get it now this
is a stew
not a soup oh yeah i totally get it now
the second i took a bite it's like a
beautiful
hearty yummy stew but when you think
about a soup i go to kind of a brothy
place and i think how's this all gonna
work this is totally a stew i think the
broth is the least of my worries in this
so
i just think you know it's like when you
invited everyone to the party but your
house just isn't big enough you know
no i totally can get down with this i am
into this it's a holiday stew okay that
that word makes it better for you i
notice
we call it a stew berry more
moving right back
[Music]